[Musik]
NRW verbrennt Millionen corona-masken
und Schutzkittel die AFD wird zehn ein
Tag in dem sich die anderen
parteiengedanken über eigene Fehler
machen sollten viel gibt es zu
besprechen heute bei viertel nach acht
heute mit diesem Gästen im bayerischen
Arzt Friedrich Pirna der wegen Kritik an
seiner corona-politik seinen Job als
Leiter eines Gesundheitsamts verloren
hat und heute sagt jetzt muss Lauterbach
seinen Job verlieren zum 10 geburtstag
der AFD gibt's Kritik von allen Seiten
NZZ Edelfeder Alexander dreht den Spieß
mal um und sagt die Stärke der AFD das
ist auch die Schwäche der anderen
hasspredigen auf offener Straße das muss
Deutschland unterbinden das sagt meine
Kollegin Bild Redakteurin Zara riffler
mit Blick auf die Koran Demonstrationen
in Hamburg denn solche Veranstaltungen
sein eigentlich nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs seine Partei kämpfte im
Berliner Wahlkampf um jede Stimme
aktuell liegen sie bei knapp 5% FDP
Politiker Tobias Bauschke kämpft um die
Stimmen auf der Leistungsträger die sich
für ihren Erfolg vielleicht auch meinen
Porsche gönnen und sagt Schluss mit
dieser Neidgesellschaft
10,6 Millionen corona-masken 1,4
Millionen Schutzkittel dazu eine
Millionen Schutzbrillen 100.000er
Handschuhe all das wird in
Nordrhein-Westfalen thermisch entsorgt
also auf gut deutsch es wird verbrannt
weil angeblich das
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum abgelaufen ist
das gab die Landesregierung nun bekannt
eingekauft wurde dieses Material unter
dem damaligen Ministerpräsidenten Armin
Laschet der das übrigens zum Teil über
Kontakte seines
influenza-laschet bestellt hatte er die
Empörung ist wo ist quer durch alle
Medien wirklich neu sind solche
Meldungen nicht Sachsen Sachsen-Anhalt
Thüringen muss mehrere hunderttausend
Impfdosen zerstören und auch der Bund
gehabt zu dass 4,6 Millionen Dosen
abgelaufen sein erleben wir hier eine
Steuergeld Vernichtung in astronomischer
Höhe wer hat da den Überblick verloren
wer trägt da die Verantwortung wenn
gleichzeitig die Bürger mit innere
höheren Abgaben belastet werden das
Besprechen werden
sie waren zu Beginn der corona-krise
noch Chef eines Gesundheitsamts während
sie damals erlebt wurde da erstmal
gekauft gekauft gekauft was nur geht
also am Anfang der corona-krise war es
ja so das ist mir gar kein Material da
war das ging relativ schnell zu Ende das
Material und dann wurde versucht zu
kaufen soweit eben noch ging das gelang
aber nicht mehr die Gesundheitsämter
waren relativ schnell am Ende mit dem
Material und dann kam ja tatsächlich
diese diese Geschichte auf mit den
community-masken mit den Stoffmasken wo
ich dann auch relativ schnell gesagt
habe na ja das ist alles andere nur
keine Schutzmaßnahme sondern das ist
vielleicht ein netter solidarischer Akt
aber eine tatsächliche Schutzwirkung hat
es nicht um das ganz kurz zu machen wir
waren also keinesfalls vorbereitet auf
diese Pandemie in Sachen Schutzmaterial
also erstmal musste dann wenn es gab
gekauft werden richtig lustige gekauft
werden und zum Teil zu wirklichen
Preisen und jetzt wird aber alles
verbrannt das merkt man auch brauchen
wir gar nicht alles das Zeugnisse
Ablaufdatum und so wie hört sie das
nicht
Empörung finde ich das falsche Wort ist
verwundert mich tatsächlich es gibt ja
wohl anscheinend der Verfallsdatum ich
frage höfliche Form der Empörung glaube
ich die Verwunderung ja wie viele hier
höflich bleiben ich frage mich halt
warum kann man das vielleicht in
anderweitig nutzen vielleicht kann man
seine warum bringt das nicht in andere
Länder die vielleicht auch brauchen
können ich will ja auch den Sinn und
Zweck von Masken gar nicht abstreiten
aber eben nur in bestimmten settings in
bestimmten Fällen ich bin mir sicher
dass andere Länder davon profitieren
könnten die jetzt einfach thermisch zu
verwerten es ist heißt auf gut auf gut
deutsch einfach zu verbrennen weil man
so
wahnsinnig viele gekauft haben sind ja
Steuergelder also eigentlich wäre nett
Masken verbrannt sondern es werden die
Steuergelder verbrannt und das verwundet
mich schon sehr ja ja Verwunderung
Empörung vielleicht bei Herrn ist gerade
angesprochen er geht zum Steuergelder im
Prinzip ein Steuergelder verwandt ja und
Steuergeld ist ja schon eine
Beschönigung Verstandes Sachverstandes
es ist ja Geld der Steuerzahler es ist
unser Geld das ist nicht das Staatsgeld
ist nicht Steuergeld sondern Geld der
Steuerzahler dass der Staat
treuhänderisch bekommen hat und es im
Sinne der allgemeinen zu verwenden und
bei diesem Beispiel gerade in der
corona-krise aber vielen anderen sehen
wir einfach dass die
Verantwortlichkeiten erodieren dass es
im Endeffekt bei großen großen Ausgaben
wie auch bei großen Versagen kein gibt
der die Verantwortung übernimmt dass ich
hinstellt es werden auf Prozesse auf
Notlagen verwiesen auf strukturdefizite
auf Zwangslagen die man habe müssen
befolgen man hat anfangs zu wenig Masken
gehabt dann viel zu viel und was ich den
Skandal fast schon finde ist zum einen
ähm wir hören bei Lebensmittel ständig
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum das ist nur
eine unverbindliche Richtschnur also man
kann die Milch auch noch eine Woche
später trinken bei Dosen ein halbes Jahr
noch länger warum muss das jetzt glaube
ich eingehalten werden zweitens ist
verbrennen ist natürlich vom Symbolwert
ein sehr dramatischer Vorgang dort wird
wirklich unser Geld verbrannt hätten wir
wirklich eine andere Lösung finden
müssen und das dritte was mich dann doch
am meisten oder am ehesten gehört ist
die Tatsache dass wir Grund zur
Vermutung haben das zu überteuerten
Preisen eingekauft worden ist er gibt
auch teilweise Untersuchungen
Untersuchungsausschüsse wir haben
teilweise betrug auch mit Corona
Teststationen also es haben sich leider
sehr viele Leute in dieser Pandemie die
Taschen voll gemacht und erschließt sich
der Kreis zu dem was Sie gesagt haben es
liegt daran dass es keine Pläne gab bzw
es gab pandemie-plänen und die wurden
nicht befolgt das heißt wir haben große
Städte die immer sagen wenn was ganz
schlimmes passiert ist sagt ja Schulze
auch immer dann mache ich nur eine
Schublade auf ist ja nur ein Plan drin
dann ist der Plan wieder veraltet und
man befolgt ihn nicht also wir haben
nicht nur ein Umsetzung sondern auch
einer kenntnisproblem das hat mich nicht
das müssen wir den Arzt ziehen unsere
Hunde Fragen das Ablauf
Mindesthaltbarkeit bei so einer
Schutzweste das ist mir nicht ganz klar
gibt's da ein Grund aus ihrer Sicht also
können Sie uns das erklären
das einzige was man vielleicht
vernünftigerweise oder anziehen könnte
deswegen das Argument das Materialien
natürlich auch im Laufe der Zeit einfach
ermüden und vielleicht deshalb nehmen
wir so gut funktioniert aber ich denke
mir ist entschieden der ganzen Pandemie
wir haben da viel zu wenig Datum ich
schätze mir auch diese diese Daten sind
einfach gewürfelt worden man hat gesagt
naja so ungefähr wird es schon passen
ich kann mir ganz schwer vorstellen
dass es jetzt sein muss dass man es
genau jetzt zu diesem Datum jetzt
einfach verbrennen muss ich komme gut
vorstellen dass die mindestens noch ein
Jahr länger halten würden und so auch
sind und Zweck erfüllen
da gab es viele Bereicherungen mit
Masken mit allen möglichen Deals die
dort geschlossen wurden wir haben das
jetzt eben gerade auch in der Sendung
schon gehört ich habe mir auch ein paar
Beispiele in Bayern Frau Hohlmeier
Andreas Handler die Tochter von dem CSU
konnte die hat Millionen abgesand
einfach nur für die Vermittlung
48,3 Millionen Euro Honorar hast du den
Eindruck der wurde quasi auf Teufel
kommen raus bestellt auch um sich
einfach finanziell zu bereichern und
dein Geschäft zu machen
ja also das war ja das lag ja schon ganz
nah beieinander die ist auf Teufel komm
raus jetzt schnell was zu beschaffen und
dann der persönlichen Kontakte anzurufen
sage ich jetzt erst jetzt Armin Lasche
der beispielsweise seinen Sohn gefragt
hat ob er ihn vermitteln kann in Kontakt
zum Unternehmen wo angeblich keine
Provisionen geflossen sind und man hat
es ja auch dann so vom Land NRW zum
Beispiel spezifisch gesehen die haben
eine Ruhe bekommen dafür dass der
Landesrechnungshof gesagt hat ihr habt
es viel zu großzügig ausgelegt dass die
Vergabebestimmungen von den Aufträgen
her was er sowieso schon gelockert wurde
im März 2020 vom Bund und der NRW
Gesundheitsminister hat ja auch nach dem
Motto so gesagt damals ja wenn wenn man
den Landesrechnungshof nicht am Arsch
kleben hat nach der Pandemie dann hat
man irgendwas falsch gemacht damit
wollte er natürlich auch ähnliches
rechtfertigen was nun diese Richtung
geht fangen wir mal direkt bei der
Politik nach waren unsere Steuergelder
da gut aufgehoben während der Pandemie
wurde verantwortungsvoll mit unseren
Steuergeldern umgegangen also ich glaube
wir haben viele Punkte über die wir
reden müssen was in der Pandemie falsch
gelaufen ist
sicherlich auch beim Thema Vergabe
Beschaffung ich nicht zu Unrecht gibt es
da auch parlamentarische
Untersuchungsausschüsse die auch
eingefordert werden ich glaube da ist
einiges zum Aufarbeiten
wobei ich ein bisschen in der Diskussion
vielleicht für den ausgleichswagen will
wenn ich mich zurück ins Sinne als
Corona ausbrach im Februar 2022 März
2020 dann hatten wir schon die Situation
dass wir wirklich gar nichts hatten da
war der Ruf nach Masken nach
Schutzausrüstung relativ stark und da
war es natürlich so und da verstehe ich
auch jeden Landrat da verstehe ich jeden
grießmanager der sagt ich beschaffe was
irgendwie geht die Frage ist sozusagen
für mich wann wurden die Sachen erstmal
gekauft
das hätte ich ihn ja jetzt gerade gesagt
also
gerade sozusagen gesagt ich glaube das
Thema Maske ist vielleicht gar nicht das
und was ich mich jetzt aufregen würde
ich würde mich eher aufregen beim Thema
z.B Corona Test also was ist da alles
schief gelaufen warum haben wir da
keinen Kontrollmechanismus eingezogen
warum wurde das sind überprüft
persönliche Kontakte auch das sind
Punkte die aufzuklären sind aber dass
ich als das Landrat der zum Beispiel
Verantwortung trägt im Krisenfall und im
Katastrophenfall was es war einfach in
dem Zeitpunkt wo mich die Krankenhäuser
anrufen ich habe keine Masken dann
vielleicht auch 150 oder 250 Prozent vom
Bedarf bestelle verstehe ich in der
politisch aufgeheizten Situation wir
haben so viele Fragen über die wir uns
ernsthaft unterhalten müssen das Thema
Masken ist ein Beiwerk aber dann lasst
uns lieber darüber sprechen was
sozusagen Anstand in dem Frage ist und
ich glaube jetzt sich darüber
aufzubringen dass er was ausläuft denn
wir hatten sie so viele Skandale von
Masken Affären also das war ja wirklich
eine Zeit lang war man beschattet von
diesen Nachrichten darüber und hat man
sich dann natürlich auch die Frage
gestellt in diesem Land wie nah ist
eigentlich Lobbyismus und Korruption
gerade wenn dann irgendeine Krise kommt
und wie weit wird das dann ausgenutzt
vom Politikern da waren sehr sehr viele
dabei die sind natürlich auch
nachweislich ausgenutzt haben und man
kann es nicht schön reden es mit den
Test das ist auch ein Problem aber was
sieben eines ist Verhältnis der Kosten
setzen im Verhältnis zu den Kosten zu
dem Masken
ursprüngliches Problem was wir haben in
Deutschland wir waren gar nicht darauf
vorbereitet auf eine Pandemie es gab
nichts dann war die große Verzweiflung
da die natürlich ausgenutzt wurde und
die ich frage mich ernsthaft ob dieses
Land und ob die Politiker auch lernfähig
sind also wenn wir eine Pandemie wieder
kriegen würden in 10 20 Jahren
inwiefern dass ich einfach wiederholen
ja
die Politik ganz einfach nicht recht
denn es gab zu keiner Zeit einen
Zeitpunkt wo die ganze Bevölkerung
Masken brauchte und das hieß es ja auch
am Anfang hier draußen hat es persönlich
gesagt man braucht keine Masken
plötzlich braucht man Masken es wäre
viel viel klüger gewesen einfach zu
sagen wir brauchen die Masken für die
Krankenhäuser für den medizinischen
Bedarf und dann hat man es irgendwann
verteilt auf die breite Bevölkerung und
dann gingen sie natürlich auch aus diese
Masken und allein durch diese Masken und
maskenpflicht hätte man ganz ganz viel
einsparen können als ich glaube da liegt
das eigentliche Problem wir brauchen
also Konsequenzen sonst ändert sich
nicht
auch schon mittendrin in ihrer ganz
persönlichen Geschichte sie waren Chef
vom Gesundheitsamt Aichach Friedberg und
sie haben sehr früh schon sehr deutlich
Kritik geübt an den corona-maßnahmen
dann wurden sie ihres Jobs enthoben ganz
herzlich wer hat das getan wer hat es
getan also das ist natürlich immer in
unserem beamtensystem kann man das immer
schwer sagen wer hat es getan also meine
vorgesetzte Stelle die Regierung von
Schwaben hat mich informiert dass ich
mehr oder weniger von heute auf morgen
abgeordnet wäre auf andere Stelle ich
sollte da angeblich gebraucht werden zu
dem Inhalt darf ich relativ wenig sagen
Hintergrund ist aber und es ist kein
Geheimnis mehr ich habe die
corona-maßnahmen der also von der
bayerischen Politik aber auch der
Bundesrepublik natürlich auch
kritisiert und ich habe das aus
fachlicher Sicht getan ich habe nie
irgendjemanden herausgesetzt habe vorher
im Innenverhältnis
kritisiert das nennt man Demonstration
Demonstrationsrecht als Beamter die
steht mir so zu es ist aber auch die
Politik kritisiert ja ich
Ministerpräsidenten kritisiert naja ich
habe die Maßnahmen kritisiert und das
ist so Unterschied das ist schon ein
Unterschied und auch als Beamter das
muss ich einfach so sagen es steht mir
das zu ich bin Arzt ich bin Beamter und
leite eines Gesundheitsamtes und mir ist
der Schutz der Bevölkerung anvertraut
worden mit meinem Amt und wenn ich
erkenne an der Basis das bestimmte
Maßnahmen nicht so gut laufen und
einfach an Schaden andere Bevölkerung
anrichten dann ist es meine Pflicht das
zu sagen und das lasse ich mir auch
nicht nehmen zumal ich auch vom Fach bin
ja frag sie das weil ich mich frage was
ging in ihnen vor hatten sie dann das
Gefühl dieser Anruf der muss von ganz
oben gekommen sein ich weiß dass der von
ganz oben kam weil mir meine
Vorgesetzten das auch so zukommen haben
lassen wenn man hat mir immer wieder
versucht und so wurde das dann auch
immer erzählt man man hat versucht mich
oder man man sollte mich einbremsen ich
sollte nicht nach außen in die
Bevölkerung gehen und Interviews geben
denn das würde sehr wahrscheinlich oder
können es ja wahrscheinlich die
Bevölkerung verunsichern und ich habe
diese Annahme glauben Sie Markus Söder
persönlich hatte spekulieren das weiß
ich nicht das weiß ich nicht da kann ich
nur spekulieren dabei will ich es auch
belassen alles was ich gesagt habe kann
man in mein Interviews nachlesen man
kann es auf meinem Twitter-Account
nachlesen ich habe 2021 ein Buch
rausgegeben Diagnose Panik die Medaillen
kann man nachlesen da steht eigentlich
alles drin was ich intern immer
kritisiert habe und was ich an den
Maßnahmen kritisiert habe und ich finde
schon noch mal als Fachmann ich bin
Epidemiologe Facharzt für öffentliche
Gesundheitswesen steht mir diese
fachliche Kritik zu und wie man
natürlich jetzt auch sehen kann hatte
ich auch
in der Verantwortung gefühlt sie sagen
heute auch ganz klar jetzt aber jetzt
müssen Konsequenzen folgen jetzt müssen
deutliche Konsequenzen vorstellen und
ihr Thema ist heute sie sagen ganz klar
jetzt sollte der Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach ihren Job verlieren
jetzt haben sie ihre Zeit und ihre
Kamera
nein das ist vollkommen klar also Karl
Lauterbach muss als Gesundheitsminister
zurücktreten beziehungsweise ist sehr
schön wenn er wenn
vom Bundeskanzler
zurückgepfiffen würde warum weil Karl
Lauterbach ganz einfach wieder fachlich
noch charakterlich für dieses Amt
geeignet das sind zu viele Fehler
passiert man man sieht es auch immer
wieder sich artikuliert was alles
erzählt es sind viele Dinge falsch die
dir erzählt hat und nun ähm schiebte
diese Dinge die jetzt immer mehr ans
Tageslicht kommen dass wir Kritiker doch
recht hatten die schiebte jetzt auf
seine Experten zu vorher dass ich feiern
lassen als Experte plötzlich wäre er
kein Experte mehr sondern er hat nur auf
die Wissenschaft gehört also ist relativ
viel falsch gelaufen natürlich nicht nur
unter der Ägide von Karl Lauterbacher
musste schon sehen wir hatten vorher
andere Bundesregierung die ist nicht
mehr da da muss man vielleicht überlegen
ob es nicht da Amtshaftungsansprüche
gibt aber jetzt haben wir einen
Bundesgesundheitsminister der
tatsächlich in meiner in meinen Augen
fachlich und persönlich nicht in der
Lage ist dieses Amt auszufüllen und
deshalb muss er gehen das ist ihre
Forderung hier heute und sie verbinden
das natürlich auch mit der Verantwortung
die sie getragen haben sie haben auch
ihre ganz persönliche Geschichte in
dieser Pandemie jetzt sind sie vor
Gericht das ganze ist in einer Klage
sagen sie uns nehmen Sie es einmal mit
wollen sie wollen sie ihren alten Job
gerne zurück haben geht es Ihnen einen
auch darum dass sie zeigen ich kann mich
wehren und vielleicht geht's auch
anderen Menschen so wie mir sehen sie
sich da auch einfach in der
Verantwortung also das mit dem Gericht
ist mittlerweile bestätigt aber da mache
ich gar nicht so viel darüber erzählen
hat aber auch damit überhaupt nichts zu
tun ich möchte natürlich rehabilitiert
werden denn ich wurde aufs schärfste
diskreditiert ich wurde von heute auf
morgen meines Amtes in toben ich wurde
erst abgeordnet dann weiter versetzt und
das aufgrund meiner meiner
Kritik und ich war ja nicht alleine
sondern es gibt ja viele Kritiker die in
diesem in diesem pandemiezeiten
diskreditiert worden sind und da erwarte
ich ganz einfach dass die alle wieder
rehabilitiert werden und die die dazu
beigetragen haben diese Menschen zu
diskreditieren die müssen ihre
Konsequenzen ziehen und die müssen
tatsächlich ihren Job verlieren das ist
ja ein Perversität fast nicht zu
überbieten was mit uns gemacht worden
ist wir fanden kein Gehör in den
öffentlichen rechtlichen Sendern
die Kritiker also wissen wir aus auf die
sogenannten alternativen Medien und
allein durch dieses ausweichen wurden
wir gebranntmarkt man hat sich ja gar
nicht mit unseren Argumenten
beschäftigen
wo wo die die die Rechten sind die
querschwurme dass der alexander war und
nach mir noch ganz andere der Heribert
Brandl das hat überhaupt gar keinen
interessiert es hat keinen mehr
interessiert sich das für sie angefühlt
an dem Tag als sie quasi ihren Job
verloren haben sie wurden versetzt und
sie Vertrauen verloren hat sie das
verletzt hat sie das enttäuscht haben
sie das fast schon erwartet weil ihnen
vielleicht vorher signalisiert wurde
gehen sie da mal nicht zu weit also es
wurde mir so in der Form überhaupt
nichts signalisiert gar nichts in
keinster Weise ich habe tatsächlich
damit gerechnet dass das was ich mache
Konsequenzen in irgendeine Art und Weise
haben könnte aber man hat mit mir vorher
überhaupt nicht darüber angesprochen und
natürlich hat es mich getroffen denn
noch mal ich war gerade auf dem
Höhepunkt meiner Karriere wahrscheinlich
wäre es sogar noch ein Stück weiter
gegangen ich lebe auch immer noch in
diesem Landkreis wo ich vorher tätig war
also man ist nicht nur beruflich
diskreditiert und isoliert sondern
tatsächlich auch privat und persönlich
und meine Karriere ist bis zum heutigen
Tag und hat sie nichts geändert die ist
kaputt die ist zerstört fertig ja als
Beamter kann ich wenn so bleibt wie es
jetzt ist sehe ich kein Land mehr ich
kann quasi nur noch auf meine
Pensionierung warten und das ist alles
andere als schön und deshalb erwarte ich
mir natürlich schon eine Rehabilitierung
denn wir Kritiker und ich jetzt in dem
Fall wir haben unseren Kopf hingehalten
und haben frühzeitig gesagt das bestimmt
die Maßnahmen nicht richtig sind ich
denke zum Beispiel an die
Schulschließungen
mittlerweile ist man so weit dass man
das einzieht
maskenpflicht genauso habe ich mir
rechtzeitig und frühzeitig habe ich
gesagt bitte maskenpflicht auf
bevölkerungsebene das wird dann immer
gern falsch verstanden
naja es ist ein tragischer Fall von dem
wir glaube ich viele haben ne also und
der Gesundheitsminister vor ihren Spahn
schrieb ja glaube ich letztens ein Buch
über wir werden uns viel verzeihen
müssen wenn ich den Titel richtig im
Kopf habe und ich glaube in der genau in
der Situation sind wir und wenn ich die
Ausführungen höre erinnere ich mich noch
gut daran das Ende letzten Jahres die
Grünen hier in Berlin noch die
maskenpflicht wieder einführen wollten
jetzt haben wir sie zum Glück auch
abgeschafft aber wir hatten natürlich
schon auch irgendwo den Punkt wo wo eine
gewisse
große Staatsgläubigkeit und eine gewisse
Monstranz der Unterwürfigkeit genutzt
wurde um sozusagen glaube ich auch Panik
zu schüren und ähm ich glaube man muss
ja auch bei den Kritikern unterscheiden
und das ist eben das Problem was
wirklich nicht gemacht wurde ne also wir
alle kennen Zuschriften wo ich mir auch
denke mit dir brauche ich mich jetzt
vielleicht nicht drüber unterhalten aber
wenn von Fachleute ernsthafte
Kritikpunkte kommen da muss ich mich
damit auseinandersetzen und das wurde
nicht gemacht
trotzdem Gesundheitsminister am
Kabinettstisch ist er noch der geeignete
Gesundheitsminister wir suchen uns die
Minister der SPD nicht aus sondern
müssen auf dem Vorschlag der SPD
Hoffnung dass sie da gute Leute sind
das können sie so interpretieren nein
das habe ich schon auch ich glaube sogar
schon in diesem Tisch hier gesagt dass
ich der Meinung wenn das Karl Lauterbach
sicherlich nicht die beste Besetzung als
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist aber das
Vorschlagsrecht liegt hier bei der SPD
dementsprechend muss die SPD erklären
was denn gut ist analbach
es werden jetzt immer mehr für gewisse
eingeräumt Herr Kistler jetzt heißt es
auch Seiten des Gesundheitsminister die
Schulschließungen hätten nicht sein
müssen dennoch die Forderungen von Herrn
Pirna ist bisher nicht erfüllt haben wir
keine rücktrittskultur mehr nein wir
haben keine rücktrittskultur wir haben
auch keine verantwortungskultur mehr ist
herrscht die machtarithmetik in einer
derart starren Weise dass sie in
Grenzbereiche des demokratisch überhaupt
nur vertretbaren sich hinein bewegt das
bedauere ich sehr sehr wir erleben zwar
von Ihnen hier im Nebensatz geschildert
nicht nur eine Verengung der
debattenräume sondern auch eine
Verengung der Zuständigkeiten das heißt
sie die Fachkompetenz wird geringer
geschätzt es ist viel wichtiger heute
vielleicht noch viel wichtiger als
früher sich innerhalb der Partei
Karriere nach oben gedient zu haben den
Rest soll angeblich der Apparat
Schultern auch der Apparat konnte Frau
Lamprecht nicht zu einer guten
Verteidigungsministerin machen z.B und
Frau Spiegel nicht zu einer guten
Bundesfamilienministerin also da gerät
die Apparat schick denke an ihre Grenzen
die Wirklichkeit hat einen Kritiker wie
jeden rehabilitiert es sollte der Staat
ihn auch rehabilitieren und meine große
Sorge Sache ist dass wir alle mit
gewissen so sagen Verwundungen an der
Seele die wir uns vielleicht heute noch
gar nicht so ganz eingestehen wollen aus
dieser
corona-engführung der Debatte uns
herausbewegen dass wir damals gelernt
haben es gibt Zeiten da ist es nötig
Herrn Scholz dem Bundeskanzler zu folgen
wenn der sagt es gibt keine roten Linien
es gibt immer rote Läden ist ein ganz
dummer Satz den Satz hat nun mit Blick
auf den Ukraine Krieg Frau Essen die
SPD-Vorsitzende wiederholt auch da gebe
es keine roten Linien in der
Unterstützung der Ukraine die rote Linie
in Deutschland ist das Grundgesetz ist
die Tatsache dass der Souverän nur einer
ist und nämlich das Volk und leider
haben wir eine übergriffige Exekutive in
der Corona Debatte erlebt und ich kann
nur hoffen dass diese Übergriffigkeit
bei anderen Debatten bei anderen Krisen
nicht wieder aus dem Mottenkiste
hervorgeholt werden wie viele
verwöhnungen an der Seele glaubst du
haben wir davon getragen durch diese
Krise und wie wenig übernimmt die
Politik jetzt dafür die Verantwortung
erstmal muss man sagen die SPD mochte
Lauterbach ja eigentlich auch nicht
wirklich viele das muss man mal
klarstellen und diese Entscheidung ging
ja eigentlich davon Scholz aus und es
gab auch so Moment da war das eher ein
Talkshow erfolgt das er dann auch
Gesundheitsminister wurde und es gäbe
viel es hätte viele Möglichkeiten
gegeben wo er komplett falsch lag und so
viel Panik geschürt hat als
Gesundheitsminister woher hätte
zurücktreten müssen wo andere schon
längst hätten zurücktreten müssen und
hätte man das viel früher getan also es
wäre recht schwer passiert
wahrscheinlich dann hätte man sich
natürlich auch eingestehen müssen dass
man eine Fehlbesetzung hier hatte und
dass man das Panik auch eine gewisse
voraussetzung war anscheinend für diesen
Posten und ähm ja also
deine Frage jetzt wohnten wir wie viele
Verletzungen auf der Seele haben und wie
viel verarschen wie wenig Verantwortung
letztendlich dafür auch übernommen wird
ja also im Prinzip ist niemand zurück es
wird niemals zurück also im Prinzip gibt
es auch gar keine Verantwortung auf
allen Ebenen also wenn wir jetzt die
nehmen die Kinder wie die gelitten haben
mit Schulschließung mit den Masken
tragen und auch deren Eltern wie wie
Menschen gelitten haben begrenzt zu
werden wie sie also oder auch Menschen
die einfach es gibt es hatten auf die
Straße gegangen sind wir hatten das
schon oft hier in der Sendung
thematisiert die dann an den rechten
Rand gedrückt wurden von der Politik wir
haben auf so vielen Ebenen Menschen die
so viel Folgen tragen psychisch seelisch
körperlich von der Pandemie und vor
allem von der Politik und ich glaube
auch gar nicht mehr daran dass ein
Politiker sich da hinstellt und wirklich
sagt ich habe ein Fehler gemacht und
mehrere Fehler und ich trage hier die
Verantwortung und zeige das und das auf
ich glaube nicht dass es passiert und es
ist scheiße es wird es jetzt eigentlich
das nächste fast geben das melden sich
immer mehr Menschen Herr Penner die
Impfschäden haben die nach der Impfung
an Krankheiten leiden die eigentlich
teilweise am Leben gar nicht mehr
teilnehmen können ist das das nächste
große fast das aufgemacht werden muss
auch dazu wenig Verantwortung übernommen
wird diese große fass ich kann mich
daran erinnern ich saß in einer anderen
talkshot gings um den Herrn Kimmich
ihren Fußballer der sich nicht impfen
lassen wollte
natürlich sagte damals der hat
vollkommen Recht war einfach sagte naja
so diese Langzeitfolgen das sei noch
nicht so ganz klar jeder der mit Medizin
zu tun hat der weiß dass Medikamente
Nebenwirkungen haben können das geht gar
nicht anders da ja das das wurde aber
gerade bei der Impfung überhaupt das
wurde komplett ausgeblendet und und das
ist ein Unsinn und der Herr Lauterbach
hat es noch getwittert und der hat bis
heute nicht zurückgenommen zumindest
nicht auf Twitter das ist keine
Nebenwirkungen bzw die Impfung
Nebenwirkungsfreiheit das ist absoluter
Unsinn und wir schauen dazu wenig hin
und diese diese Impfung die wird
beworben und beworben und immer noch und
immer noch und es gibt longovic und das
will ich auch gar nicht verneinen das
kennen wir von anderen Erkrankungen aber
genauso gut aber natürlich müssen wir
auch die Leute jetzt in den Fokus nehmen
die sagen nach der Impfung habe ich
bestimmt die Schäden aber das wird
ausgeblendet und warum warum weil man
mit einer Wucht diese Impfung über
Deutschland gestreut hat und zwar dann
auch noch mit einer sektoralen
Impfpflicht eine absoluten unglücklichen
und natürlich dieses vollkommene
unsinnige zwei g ja und damit haben ein
riesen Fass aufgemacht hätte man alles
freiwillig gelassen auch die Masken aber
vor allem auch das Impfen dass man
einfach nur eine Empfehlung
ausgesprochen hätte für bestimmte
Personengruppen dann wäre das alles gar
nicht so schlimm geworden auch nicht die
Spaltung und dann hätten sich in Ruhe
auch mal diese Impfschäden angucken
können und ich bin mir sicher man hätte
die dann ganz anders der aufarbeiten
können jetzt ist es aber fast nicht
möglich denn mit jedem Impfschaden der
jetzt aufkommt und dem man nachweisen
kann bröckelt das ganze System und das
ist brandgefährlich für die Politik
Einsatz vielleicht nur weil sie den
Kimmich erwähnen das ist wirklich ein
ein Dokument der Schande man kann es
heute noch anschauen dieses
inquisitorische Interview dass er da im
zweiten deutschen Fernsehen im Sport
Studio gegeben hat oder gegeben hat
müssen auf Anraten seines Vereins er
wurde also dort wirklich peinlich
gefragt es war eine mittelalterliche
Gesprächsführung im schlechten Sinne er
sollte zu Kreuze kriechen hat es dann
später auch gemacht er musste Abbitte
leisten vor einem Millionenpublikum
Ersatz zerknirscht aus unglücklich er
hat letztendlich dann die schuldforme
gesprochen die man von einer Watten hat
erwartet hat also leider Gottes haben
auch weite Teile der Medien dermaßen
versagt innerhalb der corona-pandemie
dass man sich wie ein Vertrauensverlust
nachhaltiger Art in die Medien
eigentlich gar nicht beschweren kann ich
möchte nur ganz kurz an was erinnern zum
Beispiel
infektionsschutzgesetze Paragraph 28c ja
der gibt immer noch so steht es auf
jeden Fall drin
die möglichen dass der Gesetzgeber
wieder eine Verordnung treffen kann dass
man wieder
impfen kann und das nur geimpfte
bestimmte Dinge machen dürfen und die
ungeimpften eben nicht und alles wird
abgestellt auf diese Immunität die haben
wir aber nicht wir haben mit dieser
Impfung zum Beispiel keine Immunität es
wurde aber ganz ganz lange erzählt diese
Impfung würde uns aus der Pandemie
bringen die sie Impfung würde uns immun
machen das wissen wir aber schon ganz
lange das ist nicht so ist die
Impfpflicht die sektorale Impfpflicht
galt aber noch bis zu Ende es war keiner
in der Lage zu sagen wir heben jetzt
diese Impfpflicht einfach mal und sie
wurde ja auch eine kontrolliert ne also
das ist ja noch nicht das ist ja noch
der nächste Punkt also wir haben die
Impfpflicht die sektorale auch immer
sehr kritisch gesehen insbesondere war
ja auch wirklich viele Fachleute auch
Professor schräg und sowas klar gemacht
haben es hilft ja auch nichts und ähm
ich fand es in Berlin wirklich
bezeichnet wie wir hier eine
gesundheitsenatorin haben die dann auch
sich hinstellen und sagte kontrollieren
es auch gar nicht aber wir müssen es
beibehalten im Zweifel sogar verlängern
wo ich dann auch mich irgendwann Frage
also was machen wir als Gesetzgeber für
Gesetze also das haben wir hier die
Oppositionsrolle und ich glaube auch das
war auf Bundesebene zumindest ganz gut
hinwirken dass
vieles gebremst wurde von der Panik die
sonst noch noch weiter gelaufen wäre
aber das ist schon Punkt also wir machen
Regelungen die wir nicht kontrollieren
können und wo wir uns ernsthaft über die
Sinnhaftigkeit Fragen müssen und
das müssen wir aufarbeiten vor allem
werden gerade in den Fall kenn ich hier
viele die sich dagegen entschieden haben
sich impfen zu lassen haben sich das
überhaupt gar nicht mehr getraut zu
sagen und als ich mir sie genauer
angeschaut habe habe ich bei Twitter
auch gesehen sie haben Impfstatus privat
machen sie das genau aus diesem Grund
weil man sich eigentlich nicht trauen
kann einfach zu sagen ich lass mich
nicht lesen möchte nicht aus dem Grund
sondern weiß was höchstpersönlich ist
und ich habe das mal einem einem
Vorgesetzten gesagt
die wollten das Wissen und dann sagte
ich wenn sie mir jetzt in Ordnung Stelle
sagen ob sie heute Stuhlgang hatten und
in der früh Sex mit ihrem Partner oder
mit deiner weitere dann beantworte ich
Ihnen Ihre Frage denn das ist was ganz
privates das sind medizinische Dinge und
die spielten früher überhaupt gar keine
Rolle und ich könnte mich wirklich tot
ärgern wenn ich auf Twitter immer
gelesen habe oh Gott jetzt ist jemand
positiv wir wünschen dir gute Besserung
Gott sei Dank bist du geimpft und so
weiter das spielt ihr alles vorher
überhaupt keine Rolle die sind private
Dinge das sind medizinische Dinge die
dürfen überhaupt gar nicht Einzug halten
ins Privatleben das geht Sie sie und sie
nichts an ob ich
würden Sie heute Menschen empfehlen sich
impfen zu lassen das kommt drauf an das
kommt tatsächlich darauf an also ich
habe ganz früh gesagt diese Impfung die
Empfehlung würde ich so machen wie bei
der Grippe also angelehnt an die Grippe
ab 60 aufwärts wohl in arabische Gruppen
ähm und natürlich auch jüngere die
bestimmte Vorerkrankungen haben aber
aber jetzt kommt mit einer richtigen
ordentliche Aufklärung und als steht es
mir ganz einfach nicht zu darüber zu
befinden wenn jemand sagt nein ich will
nicht geimpft werden dann muss ich das
als Arzt hinnehmen hauptsache ich habe
meine
Aufklärungspflicht erledigt aber ich
darf gar keinen drängen und für mich war
das dermaßen schlimm das sogenannte
impfkommandos in die Altenheime
eingerückt sind und dann haben die Leute
einfach geimpft und es kam mir keiner
sagen wirklich dass die ordentlich
aufgeklärt worden sind denn ich weiß aus
zahlreichen Mails dass Menschen geimpft
worden sind die am Ende ihres Lebens
waren und da rede ich jetzt nicht von
Jahren sondern es ging zum Teil um
Stunden und Tage ja die vor sich hin
verzeihen Sie mir den Ausdruck vor sich
hin vegetierten und trotzdem noch
geimpft wurden in den letzten Stunden
ihres Lebens und das ist für mich
absolut unethisch also ja Impfung kann
man darüber reden aber bitte man muss
ordentlich aufklären man muss ordentlich
aufgeben man braucht dafür
verhältnismäßig kalt
und man muss das unbedingt unbedingt
freiwillig machen ich habe letztens so
ein Bild gehabt da habe ich mir auch
gedacht diese Verhältnismäßigkeit ist so
verloren gegangen dass stand ich am
Straßenrand und ein Auto ist vorbei
gefahren das hat also eine Person drin
und die hat eine Maske getragen ähm
alleine im Auto wo ich mir gedacht habe
ne also das gibt's ja wirklich und es
gibt so Situationen also
bin härter Fan da leidet man momentan
immer aber
ich hatte maskenpflicht noch im Zug ne
mit der S-Bahn beim hinfahren muss sich
die Maske tragen im Stadion Ängste Raum
alles eng gar kein Problem also es war
halt auch idiotisch was wir da zum Teil
gemacht haben und das war die Menschen
auch nicht mehr erklärbar und ich glaube
großes Problem wenn man vor allem bei
den ganzen seelischen Bereichen haben
das merke ich momentan auch vor allem
auch bei Kindern ganz ganz großes Thema
dass die Politik auf keinen Fall aus den
Augen verlieren darf ganz klar ist diese
Krone Zeit das war ganz viele Spießruten
Lauf viele Menschen fühlten sich
weggedrängt fühlten sich als
corona-kritiker an den gedrängt eine
Partei muss man sagen die ist da
deutlich gegen den Strom geschwommen in
dieser Zeit die wird jetzt 10 und das
obwohl sie schon mehrfach tot gesagt
wurde ja die AFD steht jetzt beim Bund
bei rund 12 Prozent und sie sagen das
ist auch den etablier etablierten
Parteien zu verdanken das ist ihr Thema
jetzt ja die AFD AFD die Alternative für
Deutschland wurde vor zehn Jahren
gegründet die Glückwünsche vielen sehr
spärlich aus die Frage die mich
allerdings doch stellen muss warum gibt
es sie und warum gibt es sie immer noch
und diese Frage kann ich mit einem Satz
hier beantworten die AFD füllt die
Lücken die die anderen Parteien lassen
und zwar von Anfang an 2013 hat Frau
Merkel gesagt die Rettung des Euro und
die Euro Rettungspakete sind
alternativlos dann haben
Wirtschaftsleute gesagt nein das ist
nicht alternativlos wir müssen nicht mit
Milliarden deutschen Steuergeld in Euro
retten und schwuppdiwupps statt eine
Alternativen losen Politik gab es eine
Alternative für Deutschland
2014 stand die fast schon wieder vor dem
Aus es gab jede Menge Austritte und aus
der Hebamme Frau Merkel wurde dann die
Krankenschwester Frau Merkel die nämlich
lebenserhaltende Maßnahmen am Leib der
siechen afd-vornahme durch ihre
willkommenspolitik durch ihre
Entscheidung die Grenzen nicht zu
schließen die Grenzen offen zu lassen
bildete sich ein neuer Kern von Wählern
und Politikern die sagten nein ich will
nicht einstimmen in diese
Willkommenskultur in diese Pflicht so
Willkommenskultur gewissermaßen und wer
da nicht mitmachte wurde auch geframt
als schlechter Demokrat oder als rechter
eggensteher und heute das gleiche wieder
wir haben große Probleme mit der
migrationsintegrations- und Asylpolitik
wir haben fast Rekord hohe Asyl
Erstanträge gehabt im Januar 2023 und
alle die Politiker alle anderen Parteien
sagen wir müssen die Flüchtlinge einfach
besser verteilen wir müssen bauen bauen
und werden dann sagt wie beispielsweise
AFD wir brauchen einen zuzugsmoratorium
wir müssen schauen dass weniger kommen
da will uns erstmal und die kümmern
können die da sind der findet eben
momentan außer der AFD niemanden der
diese Meinung vertritt insofern muss ich
sagen die AFD ist das schlechte Gewissen
der anderen Parteien sie ist das laute
schrille Balk von Angela Merkel und sie
wird genau so lange bleiben wie die
anderen Parteien diese Themenfelder
innere Migration Flüchtlingen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Integration
vielleicht auch Islamismus nicht
aufgreifen also noch einmal die AFD ist
das schlechte Gewissen der anderen
Parteien der Name ist konkret dann
müsste eigentlich die CDU einfach weiter
nach rechts rücken und dann
ja sie müsste zumindest mal erkennen
dass dort ein Problem gibt teilweise
wird es ja probiert ich kann jetzt keine
einzigen Partei verraten die
Lösungsvorschläge der AFD zu übernehmen
ist ja klar dann politischer Wettbewerb
aber man kann einfach nicht so tun zu
sagen dass eben alle Menschen die jetzt
im Ort demonstrieren gegen einen noch
mal zusätzlich gebautes Flüchtlingsheim
die sich fragen warum werden immer mehr
Geld ausgegeben für immer mehr
Flüchtlinge werden gleichzeitig die
Renten weniger werden die Schwimmbäder
geschlossen werden da kann ich sagen die
sind alle rechts und rechtsextreme man
macht die gewissermaßen zu Recht und zu
recht extrem wenn man sagt es gilt nur
eine Meinung ist deswegen Corona wer da
aus ausgeht ist der war dann gleich ein
Leugner ein Schwuler wer hier jetzt sagt
Stopp momentan schaffen wir das nicht
mehr da ist ein rechtsextremer und die
AFD macht auf grelle Weise auf teilweise
systemische auf strategische
populistische Weise auch muss ja keiner
gut finden aber sie nimmt diese Themen
auf und sie gibt ihn einen Raum
innerhalb des Parteien Spektrums und
dieser Raum wäre natürlich kleiner wenn
dieses Problem von allen anderen
Parteien erkannt worden wäre als Problem
zumindest und ich werfe das auch Olaf
vor ich habe mir viele Reden von ihm
angehört ein Thema was er nie anspricht
ist innere Sicherheit innere Sicherheit
ist bei der SPD als Themenfeld fast
nicht vorhanden dabei muss man sagen
gerade wenn wir die Interessenvertreter
sind der kleinen Leute der Angestellte
Handwerker müssen wir uns um innere
Sicherheit kümmern weil die können nicht
im Porsche davon fahren oder sich ins
schönen Willen verstecken die brauchen
Sicherheit auf den Straßen Tag und Nacht
also innere Sicherheit müsste eigentlich
auch in Essen sein der SPD stattdessen
sagt die SPD die AFD muss auf alle
Zeiten Paria bleiben verstehe ich aber
sie wird garantiert dadurch nicht zum
Parade dass man ihre Themen negiert und
auch die FDP grenzt sich ab und
überlässt somit zu viele Themen der AFD
ich meine 22 13 ganz kurz so 20 13 €
Rettungspolitik da hat die FDP sich
gegen den Kurs damals von Herrn
Scheffler dieser glaube ich entschieden
hat hat ein quotium innerhalb der Partei
verloren wir machen da nicht mehr mit
bei diesen Euro Rettungsmechanismus und
das hat mit Ende ist ein Impuls für für
locker und und die Kollegen die AFD zu
gründen also damals die AFD FDP hat dort
die FDP kein Heimat denen gegeben mit
diesen Rettungsmechanismus mit einem
großen Unterschied es gab damals noch
nee aber es gab damals zumindest auch
eine Diskussion in der Partei also und
der entscheidende war in Frankfurt der
Bundesparteitag ich erinnere mich noch
gut daran
aber den allgemeinen Themen auch
passiert da durch die abwenden
der AFD viele Felder aber das ist doch
genau die Frage die Frage ist doch
diskutieren wir mal die Probleme
ernsthaft oder will ich jetzt eine
Stelle Schlagzeile generieren ich weiß
schon ich sitze jetzt hier bei der Bild
sehr gut aber nein aber also wenn wir
uns mit Themen Auseinandersetzung und
Sie haben ja jetzt gerade das große
potporie aller großen Themen die uns
belasten und besorgen aufgemacht dann
muss ich mir auch mal die Zeit nehmen
dass ich mich damit auseinandersetze und
ähm das hatten wir bei der EURO Rettung
aber danach ist es uns irgendwie ein
bisschen verloren gegangen also ich gebe
ihn ja auch recht als wir 25 15 die
Situation hatten
dass wir nicht mehr registriert haben
und kapitaler Fehler also darüber müssen
wir reden wir brauchen da Ansätze und es
darf auch nicht sofort in den rechten
Raum geschickt werden ich habe erst vor
kurzem Sicherheit ich habe überhaupt
im Oktober ich habe erst im Oktober zum
Beispiel beim Thema Aufnahme gesagt wir
brauchen muratorium hier in Berlin weil
wir das gerne mal abdecken können also
wir können ja ich zu sagen aber da muss
ich sagen
setzen sich gerne mal zu uns in den
Sätzen Sie sich doch mal gerne zu uns in
den Ausschuss und hören Sie sich doch an
wenn man solche Vorschläge macht wie
schnell man dann relativ schnell im
rechten Ecke ist also ich glaube wir
haben halt auch verlernt dass wir uns
ernsthaft mit dem Thema auseinander dann
werden die Probleme immer immer jeden
Tag in die Rechtecke das ist ja das
lässt sich dahin treiben alles was ihr
AFD anfasst und manche Sachen sind davon
gar nicht so schlecht an sich allgemein
Migration das will man nicht mehr
anfassen auch die FDP die da total
einknickt und bei der SPD mein Kollege
schon richtig gesagt eigentlich faktisch
gar nicht mehr statt es ist eher eine
Symbolpolitik man sieht das bei
Innenminister von Feser wir haben eine
extreme migrationskrise seit 2016 sind
die Zahlen nicht mehr so hoch wie sie
jetzt sind was hat denn in diesem Jahr
wo es wirklich von Monat zu Monat sich
gesteigert hat wo jetzt auch im Januar
und sehen die neuesten Zahlen das ist
weiter geht die migrationskrise Januar
ist eigentlich ein schwacher Monat es
geht weiter auch über die Schweiz was
hat denn Innenministerin VESA getan sie
hatten flüchtlingsgipfel gemacht daraus
ergab sich eigentlich praktisch nichts
dann hat sie eine Aktionsplan an der
Grenze zur Schweiz gemacht der
eigentlich auch gar nichts bedeutet weil
man kann nur an einem Punkt
Grenzkontrollen machen dann kommen die
einfach über andere Wege
Asyl ist ein Menschenrecht aber wir sind
gerade an einem Punkt in Deutschland wo
wir begrenzte Kapazitäten haben wo alle
Landräte und viele Minister sagen wir
können gerade nicht mehr wir brauchen
eine Lösung wir brauchen auch eine
Begrenzung weil wir können nicht über
200.000 Menschen jedes Jahr aufnehmen
natürlich jeder der der flieht vor
politischer verfolgen zum Beispiel
natürlich muss der hier also übertragen
können das ist Menschenrecht aber wir
müssen doch darüber reden was auch
Menschen versorgen haben wie wir es
jetzt in vielen vielen Städten Dörfern
Bundesländer erleben und das findet
eigentlich auch bei der FDP nicht statt
und dann überlassen Sie dieses Thema der
Arzt
ihn doch ganz konkret sagen dann lassen
Sie mich das doch mal erklären wir
müssen zum Beispiel doch bei dem Thema
dann über die Geschichte Einwanderung
Einwanderungsrecht Aufenthaltsrecht
Arbeitserlaubnis zum Beispiel sprechen
also wenn ich Leute hier ins Land hole
oder Leute hier ins Land kommen da muss
ich ihn entweder eine Perspektive geben
oder keine Perspektive geben aber das
sind wir glaube ich die Partei die seit
Jahren sagt dass wir nach kanadischen
vorbitten einfach nahrungsrecht brauchen
in der Frage das ist bei uns seit ich
weiß seit zehn Jahren Beschlusslage
verweigert hat sich die Union der
Diskussion die bis heute der Meinung ist
wir schaffen es dass wir keinen
Einwanderungsland sind das werden wir
wirtschaftlich allein schon gar nicht
schaffen aber die Frage ist doch welche
Perspektive machen wir auf damit komme
ich auch auf das Thema Asyl und und und
und Flucht natürlich müssen wir sowas
wie Dublin in der europäische Lösung
wieder fordern also
Christian Lindner war in den letzten
Jahren nicht Bundeskanzler also und das
ist relativ einfach
darum wie Gesetze gemacht wird
Regierung ja die sorgt z.B auch für
Anreize das noch mehr Menschen kommen
doch jetzt genau
Recht hat wenn man zum Beispiel
genau die richtige Punkte was wollen wir
denn an Menschen in diesem Land das ist
doch völlig richtig dass ich jetzt jetzt
hochqualifizierte gute Menschen in den
in der Situation wo wir einen
Arbeitskraft einfach
gerade Einwanderungsrecht
gerade angesprochen
dass sie
illegale Migration mit Fachkräftemangel
vermischt da müssen wir aufpassen ich
meine es ist natürlich auch so und das
muss natürlich der AFD vorwerfen das ist
natürlich immer ein sehr schön ein
hysterischen ein sehr auf Untergang
bestimmten Ton anschlägt ich habe noch
mal alte Debatten angeschaut aus der
Anfangsphase der corona-pandemie von
Frau Weidel im Bundestag die war sie
sicher also drei Monate später sind im
Prinzip alle Läden zu und den Euro
gibt's gar nicht mehr weil wir alle
wirtschaftlich k.o sind so schlimm gab
es ja auch nicht also ja AFD steht sich
mit schrillen Forderungen mit teilweise
unklaren Abgrenzungen zum radikalen Rand
mit einer dubiosen Russland Nähe
natürlich auch selber im Weg das ist ja
völlig klar aber die anderen Parteien
müssten ebenso verräten sein diese
Mädchen nicht mitzumachen und diesen
schrillen Ton von den Themen zu
abstrahieren die damit angeschlagen
werden und vor allen Dingen nicht die
vielleicht aus Mangel an Alternativen
die Alternative Deutschland wählen in
einen Topf zu stecken ich meine man kann
nicht allen Menschen vorwerfen ihre Wahl
entscheiden und zu sagen ja das zählt
irgendwie weniger weil du willst eine
Partei die irgendwie bäh ist man muss
den wahlentscheid der einzelnen Bürger
ernst nehmen die Anliegen die hinter dem
im Wahl entscheiden steht man sagt ja
manchmal ein Schreiner Liebe jeder
wahlentscheid ist irgendwie so ein
Schrei nach Liebe und den muss man auch
ernst nehmen und darf diese Menschen die
sie wählen die nochmal von den
funktionieren zu trennen sich sind nicht
komplett aus dem demokratischen Diskurs
aus und Einsatz ist das eben fast alle
im Bundestag sagen ja alle
demokratischen Parteien hier sind sich
einig und es waren dann alle außer der
AFD der möchte ich sagen also keine
demokratische Verfahren durchläuft der
dürfte gar nicht im Bundestag sitzen
also das sind so kostenlose gratis
Gewinner der Moral wenn Sie das
Diskussionen zueinander möchte ich gerne
Ihre Meinung als Bürger hier sitzen
Journalisten ein Politiker wie wirkt das
auf sie werden zu viele Themen quasi
nicht angefasst von den etablierten
Parteien weil man sich nicht traut ja
schrecklich wirklich und
muss ich wieder zurück in die in die
pandemiezeit es wäre am schönsten
gewesen wenn die AFD gesagt hat wir
brauchen eine Impfpflicht dann wäre die
wahrscheinlich gar nicht gekommen hätte
die AFD gesagt wir brauchen eine
maskenpflicht dann wäre die
maskenpflicht ganz sicher nicht gekommen
und genau das ist übel nein das meine
ich im Ernst ich weiß das klingt
irgendwie lustig aber im Prinzip ist es
so die AFD gibt ein Stöckchen also ein
Thema vor und die anderen hüpfen drüber
indem sie aber dann nicht mehr anfassen
weiß eben verbrannt ist weil man Angst
hat dass man in die AFD nee gerückt wird
aufgrund des Themas und da kann ich auch
selbst aber Elite von Singen also wenn
ich irgendwie sollte die Maßnahmen sind
es schlecht oder oder die die Körper
besser machen und der AFD ähm
Landtagsabgeordneter oder Politiker hat
es aufgenommen dann war mein Kritikpunkt
erledigt und das ärgert mich natürlich
auch als Bürger denn das kann ich in der
ganzen Politik verfolgen und den Fehler
sollten die Politiker nicht machen man
darf natürlich die Instrumente der AFD
aufnehmen natürlich darf man das machen
warum denn nicht die AFD ist
demokratisch legitimiert die ist gewählt
ist verfasst und demokratisch gewählt
richtig ja also das haben Bürger in
Deutschland haben gewählt und das muss
man schon ernst nehmen man muss sie also
die AFD man muss sie nicht mögen aber
man muss sich mit ihr auseinandersetzen
findet nicht statt indem ich einfach die
Themen von der AFD nicht mehr aufgreifen
das ist ein Thema dass sich die AFD ganz
groß auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat und
darüber sprechen wir gleich nachher ganz
kurzen Pause hier mit meiner Kollegin
Zara riffler bleiben Sie gerne bei uns
bis gleich
[Musik]
schön dass ihr bei uns sind und bei uns
ist auch meine Kollegin Zara riffler du
ja beschäftigt sich intensiv mit dem
Islam in Deutschland und du weißt
schockiert über die Demonstrationen in
Hamburg welche Konsequenzen daraus
folgen müssen wie wir an dieses Thema
herangehen müssen das ist kein Thema
jetzt bei uns in der Sendung ja über
3.500 Menschen sind auf die Straße
gegangen Hamburg haben sich einer
islamisten-demo angeschlossen ganz
bewusst
und ich frage mich wie lange wollen wir
dem eigentlich noch zuschauen auf
unseren Straßen haben Islamisten zu
ihrem macht Demonstration gezeigt auf
unserem Straßen haben und Männer von
Frauen getrennt Kinder wohnen dort
instrumentalisiert und diese
sektenartigen Islamisten Gewinn an
Zuwachs schaffen es immer mehr Menschen
für sich zu vereinnahmen die Zahlen
steigen und wie lange wollen eigentlich
noch zuschauen wie lange wollen wir die
Anhänger noch zählen wie lange wollen
wir überhaupt noch für eine verbieten
die dann einfach sich unter neuen Namen
neu formulieren und ich glaube
deutschland ist bereit oder muss bereits
sein für einen islamismusbeauftragten
denn es ist nicht nur so dass Islamisten
die offen extremistisch sind eine Gefahr
sind vor unsere Sicherheit für unsere
Demokratie sondern auch legalistische
Islamisten die nicht mit Gewalt ihre
Ziele verfolgen und in die Politik Lobby
ihren in unsere Gesellschaft und
Islamisten haben alle dasselbe Ziel was
sie eint ähm unsere Werte unsere
Gesellschaft
abzuleben und zu ersetzen mit einem
Staat auf der Scharia aufbaut
Sarah wir hatten hier zuletzt auch in
der Sendung zwei Islamkritiker die der
eine kann ohne Polizeischutz gar nicht
mehr auf die Straße es gibt
Morddrohungen und auch du hast heute bei
diesen Thema sind viele sehr sehr
vorsichtig vor allem so sagt dass du es
auch gerade die Politik sehr vorsichtig
und du hast heute auch die Erfahrung
gemacht dass man ganz schnell auf
Twitter dann mal verschwindet wenn man
kritisch zu diesem Thema ja genau dieses
Thema nicht genug heran ja dazu muss ich
dann den Zuschauern erklären dass ich
auch Twitter über diese Demonstrationen
geschrieben habe und das ganz neutral
eigentlich quasi eingeordnet habe und
gesagt habe da ist ein Problem daraufhin
haben mich die Islamisten genau aus
dieser Bewegung dieser Gruppe ähm hieß
Utah hier ähm gemeldet und ich wurde
gesperrt und die war noch nicht sehr
erfreut dass ich dann wieder entsperrt
wurde von Twitter haben dann auch
geschrieben jetzt geht quasi die Hetze
weiter und das ist auch das was sie so
propagieren die es ist wirklich ähm also
diese Gruppe die jetzt in Hamburg dort
ähm das veranstaltet hat organisiert hat
das ist eine islamistische Bewegung auch
aus der Muslimbruderschaft entstanden
ist das heißt sie ist auch zutiefst
antisemitisch und ich frage mich wo ist
eigentlich da das nie wieder also da
haben wir auch so eine Doppelmoral
während das wirklich rechtsextreme
gewesen hätte man zu Recht gesagt das
wird verboten die werden beobachtet
diese ganze diese ganze das heißt Muslim
interaktiv diese Gruppe die das war von
der Abspaltung dieser islamistischen
historiebewegung die hätten müsste auch
verboten werden wo sind denn die
Konsequenzen ich sehe keine Konsequenzen
und das durchzieht sich eigentlich seit
Jahren unsere Bundesregierung arbeitet
mit legalistischen Islamisten zusammen
und legalisieren die quasi die sich
immer so offen und tolerant geben und
das ist gefährlich und ich frag mich wo
bringt uns das hin das wäre meine Frage
an dich das ist eine Befürchtung für uns
das hinbringt ich habe keine gute
Befürchtungen ich glaube das ist in
wenigen Jahren sogar um die Ohren
fliegen kann wir sehen uns zum Beispiel
in Frankreich wo lange auch nichts
passiert das gegen islamistische
Strukturen Bewegungen Gruppen die
Vororte in Paris mittlerweile von
Islamisten irgendwie
eingenommen sind die da das Sagen haben
die auch Frauen sagen wie die sich zu
klein haben auf den Straßen es ist dort
teilweise in manchen kleingebieten unter
aus der Kontrolle geraten und es wird
immer gesagt das wäre eine kleine Gruppe
in Wahrheit ist es so dass seit Jahren
von vielen islamistischen verschiedenen
Gruppen gibt es ja in Deutschland die
Zahlen langsam steigen und was der
Verfassungsschutz so schätzen kann da
sage ich mal Journalisten das ist nur
ein Drittel es ist mindestens zwei
Drittel mehr und auch bei dieser
Bewegung ist total hier also es geht man
davon aus dass es bundesweit 700 sind
man hat jetzt gesehen da sind 3500
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen also es
sind deutlich mehr und das ist diese
kleine Gruppe ist groß und das muss man
ernst nehmen und ich freue mich Muster
unsere Innenministerin liebt blind ist
sie auf diesem einem Auge die unseren
Islamismus Expertenkreis auch
abgeschafft hat und ich sehe keine
Islamismus Strategie ich hatte das
Bundesinnenministerium angefragt schon
vor einem Monat gibt es denn eine
Islamismus Strategie daraufhin habe ich
auch richtige Antwort gekriegt weil es
keine islamistische Strategie gibt das
ist unsere gemeinsame einmal reinschauen
der ein junger Mann sagt etwas in die
Kamera und er stand dort in Hamburg auf
der Bühne schauen sie zu
europa muss verstehen dass wir Muslime
unsere eigene Identität haben und nicht
bereit dazu sind diese abzulegen die
Assimilation der Muslime wird Ihnen
daher niemals gelingt und ist zum
Scheitern verurteilt was geht denn ihnen
vor wenn sie dem jungen Mann der dort in
Hamburg dabei war zuhören natürlich
Entsetzen wir haben viele Menschen die
islamischen Glauben sind in Deutschland
die hier in wertvoller Teil der
Gemeinschaft sind und die ich auch
definitiv in Deutschland nicht missen
will aber wir haben natürlich und das
ist ja was der gibt sicherlich bessere
Experten als ich aber das was ich
zumindest auch weiß dass wir beim
Islamismus natürlich schon auch ein Feld
eine politischen Strömung haben die
massiv auch Einfluss gewinnen will und
das ist natürlich
gerade erwähnt hat
ihre Regierung sitze ihre parteisitzer
mit in der Regierung sage erschreckend
sitzen wir nicht mit in der Regierung
erst am Sonntag dann hoffentlich aber
aber ja klar aber wenn ich mir jetzt mal
anschaue wäre die letzten 16 Jahre des
Innenministerium belegt hat dann würde
ich da mal hin auch definitiv die Fragen
stellen also
bin jetzt kein kein Bundespolitiker
dementsprechend tue ich mich bei dem
Thema schwer wir haben natürlich aber
auch in Berlin spezifisch da ganz ganz
große Herausforderung ich glaube es ist
natürlich auch ein Thema wo wir
insbesondere in den Ballungszentren uns
auch noch mal über wahrscheinlich über
eine andere Strategie unterhalten müssen
als jetzt vielleicht im im schwäbischen
Gemeinwesen aber
klar brauchen wir deine Strategie wir
brauchen Vorgehen reden sie darüber
rede ich selten dazu
sind sie auch im Wahlkampf von der
möchte man vielleicht so ein Thema auch
gar nicht anfangen auf jeden Fall fassen
wir solche Themen an aber ich glaube für
solche Themen haben wir wirklich in
Experten die ihnen da wesentlich mehr
helfen als ich als Gesundheits- und
Sozialexperte wo wir aber auch gerne
darüber uns unterhalten können und das
ist glaube ich einerseits natürlich eine
Strategie gegen Islamismus auch was
innenpolitisch ist was rechtspolitisch
ist aber wir müssen natürlich auch an
das ganze Thema Integration gehen wir
müssen alles ganze Thema
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt gehen
Wertevermittlung was fordern wir ein
Stichwort jetzt auch Silvester was wir
da hatten
ich glaube da können wir uns gerne
darüber unterhalten aber aus
innenpolitischer Sicht muss ich Ihnen
leider heute sagen da bin ich sicherlich
der falsche Ansprechpartner auch hier in
der Hauptstadt wo 34%
Migrationshintergrund haben nicht allein
muslimischen Hintergrund aber das müsste
doch auch ihr großes Thema sein ist
mitten im Wahlkampf
also wir haben ein großartigen
indexperte mit der auch regelmäßig hier
zu Gast ist der das Thema ja für uns im
Ausschuss auch betreut ja du sagst die
Probleme werden nicht klar benannt da
gibt es keine Strategie wer muss sich
dieser Strategie jetzt annehmen welche
Forderungen müssen da jetzt auch kommen
ist das also immer dass man einfach
loslässt also es ist so wir haben so
viele Beauftragte für so viele Dinge und
wieso haben wir kein Islam beauftragten
mal ehrlich wir haben zum Beispiel eine
Integrationsbeauftragte die selbst mit
legalistischen Islamisten sich schon
getroffen hat und den Geld gibt wie
unsere Zeitung berichtet hat und das
haben wir auch in anderen Ministerium
der Fall und da brauchen diese Politiker
noch selbst ein Berater an ihrer Seite
der Ihnen sagt ihr erkennt das nicht
oder wollt es nicht erkennt schaut hier
das sind
tanislamisten und er für die offen
Extremisten wo man das ganz offen sieht
das gefährlich ist ja ist hier es wird
total verkannt gerade seit der Pandemie
weiß natürlich auch untergegangen ist
weil man das gar nicht mehr genau
beobachten kann das erstens die seiner
fistischen Gruppierungen in Deutschland
wieder total Anfahrt aufgenommen haben
seit 2022 haben wir wieder Street da war
auf den Straßen ganz Deutschland das
wird verkannt und diese Salafisten die
sympatisieren auch offen mit dieser
islamistischen Bewegung mit denen wir es
in Hamburg zu tun haben und das ist eine
neue islamistengeneration quasi die sich
in Kapuzenpulli gibt in der Jeans die
auch so tut ja als hätten wir als hätten
die manche offenheiten liberale was
natürlich faktisch nicht so ist die sich
nicht mehr mit Bart oft und lang gewandt
zeigen und man hat mal wir haben ja
dieses Video gesehen wo auch der Mann
spricht von diesen Namen von denen sind
auch verschleiert also die geben nicht
wirklich preiswerter hinter steckt und
die versuchen auch an Menschen wirklich
sektenartig ranzugehen indem die
Menschen in Universitäten Moscheen und
woanders privat versuchen anzutreffen
eine Freundschaft aufzubauen und sich
noch gar nicht offenbaren das ist
wirklich sektenartig und dann erst
später zeigen sie überhaupt was für
Ideologien sie haben wenn sie die schon
von sich überzeugt haben und wenn wir
den Anspruch haben müssen und ich finde
es müssen wir haben wirklich jeden zu
integrieren so weit es geht dann müssen
wir das ändern
Sie den Eindruck das ist ein Thema das
wir haben das gerade so ein bisschen
gesehen heißt das Eisen ist das will man
eigentlich nicht anfassen vor allem
nicht mitten im Wahlkampf lässt man
lieber die Finger von ja zumindest
auch immer man hat es eben leicht auch
in seiner Antwort hier gemerkt man geht
dann sofort zur nächsten Notausfahrt und
Notausfahrt heißt dann
Integrationsbemühungen steigern oder
Frau Frau giffe hier die noch regierende
kommissarische Bürgermeisterin sagte ja
wir müssen die Jugend und Elternarbeit
intensivieren da kann ich so sagen
verdammte Axel geht hier am Straftaten
wenn ich also Leute durch
Integrationsarbeit die Schweine wie viel
Geld kosten beibringen muss schieße
keine Böller in die Augen von anderen
dann bin ich eigentlich schon jenseits
dessen was unter normalen Menschen sich
als Mensch sich verstehen soll das heißt
wir reden hier von Straftaten wenn in
Muslim interaktiv vorher eine Demo macht
den Hamburger minutenlang gerufen wird
Kindermörder Israel dann ist das eine
anti-semitische Phrase eine Straftat die
muss geahndet werden dann kann man nicht
Stunden oder Minute rumstehen und sagen
wir beobachten erstmal und hoffen dass
wir keins auf die Rübe kriegen genauso
diese Demonstration macht Demon der
Grauen Wölfe die türkische
Rechtsextremisten sind das die Trend
auch Islamist auch Islamisten genau
treffen sich in öffentlichen Gebäuden in
Deutschland offenbar ist es kein großes
Problem stellen da Videos ins Internet
auf Facebook wo man sieht wie also
kleine Kinder mit Maschinengewehren und
im halb unten im Hintergrund posieren
gewissermaßen für ein Krieg oder für ein
kriegerisches denken abgerüstet werden
sollen es heißt es fehlt hier einfach
die Bereitschaft bei dieser Form des
Extremismus das Islamismus genauso oder
mindestens genauso scharf hinzuschauen
wie bei anderen Form des Extremismus der
uns schadet und es fällt auch oft die
Bereitschaft deshalb dahin zu schauen
weil man denkt na ja wir wollen es ja
nicht unter Rassismus Verdacht kommen
aber da haben sie wieder um Punkt recht
es gibt sehr sehr viele weit weit
überwiegende Mehrheit der hier lebende
Muslime sind Gesetze treu und ich mache
denen eigentlich das Leben schwer wenn
ich die gesetzeslosen nicht beobachte
weil ich sage ach da bin ich Rassist
nein Rassist ist der der wegschaut weil
er meint er müsst ihr einen gewissen
kulturellen Rabatt geben
aber dafür brauche ich halt auch
Regulierung ne wenn ich mir das
polizeiaufgabengesetz hier in Berlin zum
Beispiel anschauen
Landespolitiker aber dann habe ich doch
natürlich dieses Problem ne also ich
brauche natürlich auch eine Polizei und
Sicherheitsbehörden die ausgestattet
sind dass sie ihren Job machen können
also ich glaube nicht unbedingt dass es
die Jobbeschreibung ist ein Beispiel für
mich was ich immer noch faszinierend
finde das Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz in Bremen glaube ich
hat insgesamt 47 Planstellen ich frage
mich wie ein Amt mit 47 Planstellen also
sie waren ja Amtsleiter da wissen Sie
was auch alles dazu zählt aber die sind
ja zuständig die beobachten ja aber da
zählt die da zählt die sekretariatskraft
dazu da zählt die Pforte dazu dann
rechnen Sie mal runter wie viele
Menschen denn da wirklich in der
Ermittlung sind und wenn wir uns über
Bremen unterhalten haben wir ja in
Bremen wirklich ein Hotspot der Szene
was ich zumindest jetzt sozusagen ein
bisschen aus dem journalistischen
Kontext kenne dann habe ich natürlich
hier keine Ausstattung oder
jetzt kommen wir von Berlin quasi nach
Bremen aber fehlt ihrer Partei Fehler
vielleicht zu Leute die sich an solche
Themen ran trauen die da mehr Klartext
reden so wie früher ich weiß nicht in
Westerwelle in Genscher der einfach mal
also
Marco Buschmann der ja heute in ganz
akuten Vorschlag gemacht hat was auch
den Datenaustausch zwischen dem Behörden
also die Leute fehlen ihnen nicht nein
also ich glaube Marco Buschmann ist ein
Teil eines guten Teams und ähm Wahlkampf
ich glaube auch dass man da oft die
Vergangenheit etwas glorifiziert ich
kann mich gut daran erinnern dass auch
Guido Westerwelle nicht immer leider der
große Held in der Nation war sondern
auch damals kritische tone aushalten
musste ein Thema dass die FDP auf jeden
Fall beherrscht ist das Thema Wirtschaft
und da brauchen wir wieder mehr Menschen
die richtig Lust haben auf Erfolg und
auf Leistung und das ist ihr großes
Thema unbedingt wir
glaube ich müssen uns ehrlich machen
denn was unser Land angeht brauchen wir
wieder eine Leistungsbereitschaft ich
glaube ganz fest davon dass ich
überzeugt bin dass es nur bergauf geht
in Deutschland wenn der Sportwagen
wieder eine Art Motivation ist eine Art
der Anstrengung ist und nicht weiter der
stieg mal das scheinbar moralisch
schlechten Menschen und dafür brauche
ich einen schlanken und effizienten
Staat ich brauche eine Abgaben und
Steuerordnung die vernünftig ist die den
Menschen auch wirtschaftlichen Freiraum
schenken und ich brauche auch
unkomplizierte Gesetze die ich im
Zweifel umsetze und ähm da ist ganz viel
zu tun und wir kommen allein mit der
demografischen Entwicklung jetzt glaube
ich in einen Faktor wo wir uns ernsthaft
darüber unterhalten müssen und deswegen
habe ich das Thema heute für die Runde
mitgebracht
diese kleine mini-wahlkampfrede jetzt
nein überhaupt nicht und ich bezweifler
auch ganz stark dass die FDP nach der
Wahl am Wochenende Rolle spielen wird
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen wir
könnten jetzt Wetten abschließen nein
das ist so und verteilen sie mir das
überhaupt gar nicht persönlich aber das
ist so typisches
Politiker
wie soll ich sagen die sind Einlassungen
von Politikern
nennen Sie doch mal genau wie sie denn
das machen wollen ja lassen Sie uns doch
ganz konkret darüber reden genau bitte
morgens bei ganz konkret Beispiele wie
sie denn das machen wollen wir werden an
die abgabenlastung an die Steuerlast ran
müssen mit 42,2 Prozent glaube ich sind
es aktuell haben wir die höchste Abgabe
und steuerlastung das bedeutet ja nichts
dran ändert sich seit Jahren ganz im
Gegenteil wir haben die Situation dass
wir ja gerade die Bremse auf Bundesebene
für die Linken Ausgabe Fantasien sind
das ist ja leider so die Rolle die wir
in dieser Ampelkoalition irgendwo
einnehmen müssen
aber wir haben da natürlich die
Situation dass wir daran müssen also ich
glaube
was heißt denn der schlank verstanden
im öffentlichen Dienst in Deutschland
beschäftigt ja gleichzeitig wissen sie
ungefähr wie viele Handwerker es in
Deutschland gibt oder Leute die in
Handwerksunternehmen beschäftigt sind
5,5 Millionen Menschen also wenn ich das
dagegen halte dann haben wir eine
Situation wo wir einfach einen extrem
überproportionierten öffentlichen Dienst
haben wir haben viel zu viel Verwaltung
die Verwaltung ist ineffizientes merken
wir gerade in der Hauptstadt und
anstelle dass wir eine Strategie
entwickeln stellen wir in den
haushaltsausschüssen
ich würde mich da jetzt nicht auf eine
Quote weil es natürlich immer auf die
Herausforderung angeht und die Frage ist
doch sozusagen wo Stärke ich wir hatten
das Thema doch gerade z.B beim Thema
Verfassungsschutz dass ich da jetzt
nicht unbedingt einen Stellenabbau
vornehmen kann wenn ich da jetzt gerade
ein wichtiges neues Feld hat dann ist es
richtig aber wenn ich Situationen habe
wo ich einfach merke dass wir stellen in
der normalen Verwaltung Bürgeramt hier
in Berlin oder sowas aber nicht mehr bis
jetzt bekommen weil wir die Leute nicht
mehr bekommen wir stellen und daran
binden dann ist es ein Fehler und dann
müssen wir uns noch überlegen wie gehen
wir mit Digitalisierung mit KI um es
gibt so viele Möglichkeiten und das
Problem dass wir verschlafen alles was
an der Entwicklung die Länder um uns
herum machen und wir sitzen hier so ein
bisschen bequem rum und denken uns alle
irgendwie geht es hoffentlich vorüber
die Frage ist halt nur möchte es ist mal
leicht vermitteln mit dem was sie sagen
würde ich mal sagen haben Sie eigentlich
recht mit der Diagnose
Zustandsbeschreibung der Stadt ist zu
fett er nimmt uns zu viel Geld ab er ist
so langsam Digitalisierung wir sind im
Prinzip abgehängt unser Chefredakteur
hat neulich geschrieben von der NZ für
die kommen in Deutschland gekommen in
der Dritten Welt polemisch aber manchmal
kann man das Eindruck haben er ist
Schweiz im Gegensatz zu mir darf das
sowieso schreiben nur eben ich fürchte
für diese Probleme wird man in
Deutschland die nächsten 10 20 Jahre nie
nie eine Mehrheit bekommen weil die
Deutschen einfach gewohnt sind ich
dachte immer spätestens seit
Sozialgesetzgebung die Deutschen sind
gewohnt der Staat nimmt mir meine
riesigen ab der Staat ist gewissermaßen
der doppelte Boden der mich schützt bei
kleinen und größeren Fehlern ich finde
er sollte nur vergrößer Fehler
vergrößere Notlagen schützen aber dieses
Umdenken im Kopf und das muss bei den
Deutschen stattfinden das sehe ich
gerade jetzt momentan nicht wir hatten
erst die corona-krise wo der Staat als
bigspender auftrat mit den ganzen
Rettungspaketen wir haben jetzt Ukraine
mit den ganzen energiepreispaketen
wieder big Spender Olaf Scholz hat's ja
und das ist glaube ich das Problem
deswegen müssen wir jetzt darüber reden
sich zu viele findet kein Umdenken wir
haben gerade in diesem Tisch so viel
diskutiert über so viele Themen die
wichtig sind anzugehen hast du das
Gefühl es findet einen Umdenken statt
mehr Leistung brauchen zum Beispiel in
dem Punkt aber auch dass wir uns nicht
bequem machen dass wir Leistung dass wir
was erreichen wollen dass wir das eine
Veränderung gerade in der Gesellschaft
stattfindet also es kommt drauf an also
wenn ich so meine Generation anschaue
dann kriegen sie sich gerade an die
Straße und es geht nicht wirklich nach
Leistungen deswegen können
das ja schon an dass Menschen sich
future angeschlossen haben in meiner das
hat sich zur Schule gegangen bin und so
weiter und ich erlebe ehrlich gesagt in
meiner Generation eine Müdigkeit dass
man keine Lust hat zu arbeiten ich kann
Lust hat lange zu arbeiten und das hängt
damit zusammen deswegen würde ich Ihnen
Recht geben von diesem Kerngedanke sie
sagen Leistung ist wieder was zählt was
wert sein denn ich habe das Gefühl dass
viele Menschen das ist bei den verloren
gegangen ist dass man wirklich was
leisten muss und das ist dann was wert
ist es muss halt auch wieder vorgelebt
werden also nicht glaube das ist
wirklich sowas diese also 16 Jahre lang
das All Inclusive Paket sozusagen
genutzt wir machen auch jetzt
handwerklich Fehler das freut mich auch
ein auch auf Bundesebene ich bin
entsetzt nein nein Ehrlichkeit dazu wir
machen sicherlich Punkte also werden wir
bei 50% FDP glaube ich würde die Politik
zum Teil anders ausschauen wir mussten
in den Koalition aber
wir haben natürlich schon die Situation
dass das halt gelernt werden muss es
muss auch den Leuten mal wieder erklärt
werden das Thema Eigenverantwortung
einfach ganz entscheidend ist fürs Leben
und das ist was wo ich auch merke das
auch bei vielen Diskussionen die wir
hier in Berlin wir wollen irgendwie alle
in die Hängematte befördern wir haben
doch einen ganz großes Problem und es
wird auch momentan auch von der
SPD-Regierung nicht adressiert das ist
unser Rentenproblem klar immer mehr in
die Rente ein jeder ärgert sich wenn er
seine Abrechnung bekommt wir zahlen
immer mehr ein werden immer weniger
rausbekommen sind gewissermaßen die
armen Renten von Europa und demnächst
muss ich auch noch versteuert werden
also da wird doch bewusst ein Illusion
gezüchtet als würde man mit immer
höheren Abgaben sich ein sorgenfreies
Leben im Alter garantiert und nicht ist
damit aber wir hätten doch damit z.B
auch Kreativität schauen Sie mal her
Fachkräfte Arbeitskräftemangel das sind
wir uns ja einig dass wir den in dem
Land haben und warum gehe ich nicht her
also ich habe den Vorschlag jetzt
gemacht der wurde leider wieder auf
Landesebene auch abgelehnt aber warum
gehe ich nicht her und gehe jetzt zum
Beispiel ganz massiv an pensionierte
Verwaltungs Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter die im Ruhestand sind die
aber noch fit sind die sagen ich kann
noch ein halbes Jahr ja arbeiten und
versuche jetzt zum Beispiel zu
Verwaltung
also wir sind zum Beispiel für eine
völlig flexible
Porsche der muss wieder zum Ziel werden
für die glauben sie sie können sie
kommen aus dem Gesundheitsbericht
beispielsweise bei all den Pflegerinnen
und Pfleger die von einer Pandemie
kommen die wenig verdienen die Leisten
und machen und tun und dann sitzen
Politiker und sagt naja man muss jetzt
einfach mehr leisten nehmt euch einen
Sportwagen zum Ziel meinen sie von den
holen sie wählerstunde ja wir holen auch
bei dem Pflegerinnen und Pfleger viele
Wähler Stimmen warum wenn ich im
Krankenhaus Beschäftigte mir anschaut
dann ist im übrigen das Lohngefälle gar
nicht mehr so schlecht wir reden
mittlerweile bei der Entlohnung im
Pflegepersonal im Krankenhausbereich von
einigermaßen guten Löhne aber was ist
denn dann wichtig sie wollen eine
Verlässlichkeit im Terminplan und dann
wollen die wenn die am Monatsende ihre
Lohnzettel bekommen auch noch was
rausbekommen machen was doch mal ganz
konkret wenn heute einer 4000 € brutto
verdient dann kostet ja dem Arbeitgeber
4900 € rausbekommen der 2500 €. das ist
doch das geht wo war ran müssen und
solange der Staat sich dazu bedient
haben wir doch das Problem und da freut
sich dann auch die die Pflegefachkraft
wenn wir sagen da wollen wir genau die
Entlastung wie lange soll die
Pflegefachkraft dann wenn sie Beispiele
haben dann auch arbeiten oder die die
Pflegefachkraft im Altenheim oder so
weiter also bei der Rente bei der Rente
müssen wir völlig flexibilisieren also
wir werden Berufen nein nein
keine Zeit sondern ja sehen Sie sie
machen sich jetzt ganz einfach das kann
man es machen ich wähle ja genau und
deswegen flexibilisieren ich glaube das
ist jetzt auch für sie nicht nicht nicht
zu schwierig weil es ein Unterschied ist
ob ich jetzt das Pflegefachkraft arbeite
und tagtäglich Patienten z.B umbetten
muss oder ob ich jetzt im Bürojob habe
wo ich was weiß ich in der Verwaltung
vielleicht Sitze im ganzen Tag das ist
ein Unterschied und dementsprechend muss
auch der Renteneintritt flexibilisiert
werden da wo ich der Meinung bin jetzt
ist der Punkt für mich das ich in den
Ruhestand gehen kann dann soll ich das
machen in ihrer Zucht haben wir doch
genau dieses haben wir doch genau das
beste Beispiel wie viele Ärzte schicken
wir wegen Mangel der kassenärztlicher
Zulassung offiziell in den Ruhestand und
sie behandeln dann privat weiter es
funktioniert aber gleichzeitig haben
Ärzte genau an das Thema müssen wir ran
Turner haben sie nicht
abgeguckt
ganz hässlich bei ihnen fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie
wollen bei Viertel bis dann
[Musik]